Guten Morgen Dino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du, ab und zu gibt's Dinge, die ändern einfach alles.
In diesem Jahr machen wir drei neue Podcasts. Ein über Politik, ein über Kultur und ein über das Netz.
Ja Politik, Kultur und Netz. Verstehst du? Das sind nicht drei verschiedene Podcasts. Das ist ein Podcast und wir nennen ihn Logbuch, Netzpolitik.
Aber den gibt's doch schon.
Ja genau, Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Gibt's doch schon.
Wir könnten diesen neuen Podcast iPod nennen.
Oder iPhone.
IPhone gibt's doch schon. Zehn Jahre iPhone hätte, wer hätte das gedacht.
Ja ich, sorry. Aber davon war ich in dem Moment wirklich überzeugt.
Das ist das ist das zehn Jahre lang geben.
Ja, dass das überhaupt irgendwie das Ding ist und das wird's ja eigentlich auch. Muss man, muss man mal sagen und diese Keynote war schon das Ding.
Das war ein äh eine sehr gute Keynote, ja. Da muss man sich immer noch dran messen.
Immer noch alle dran messen. Genau. Da haben sie sich.
Der der Stab über den wir jeden Speaker beim Kongress springen lassen.
Und haben auch dieses Jahr wieder genau. Ja, jetzt haben wir eine eine Pause gehabt, eine längere die war ähm.
Kongressbedingt.
Kongress bedingt weihnachtsbedingtes, übliche Päuschen am Ende des Jahres. Wir hatten ja auch festgestellt, dass so unsere zweihundertste Sendung dann tatsächlich fünf Jahre gedauert hat
sprich von einem wöchentlichen Zyklus weichen wir dann doch etwas äh ab, aber haben's immerhin so auf vierzig Sendungen gebracht. Na ja und diese Pausen sind dann halt so das, was,
da zuschlägt.
Trotzdem äh haben wir natürlich Politik, Kultur und Netz äh immer fest im Blick und von daher, ne? Und was mit Schokolade. Ja und ähm.
Werden jetzt mal langsam hier wieder in die äh Chronistenpflicht äh übergehen.
Und natürlich aber auch ein wenig über den Kongress reden, denn das ist das, was wir noch alle irgendwie so halb im Hirn haben. Wer von euch auf dem Kongress da war, kann ja mal gucken.
Ähnliche Eindrücke gehabt habt wie mir wie wir und darüber hinaus alle die nicht da waren aber es vielleicht aus der Ferne beobachtet haben.
Äh eben äh ebenso.
Wir werden jetzt hier sicherlich kein äh vollumfänglichen Rückblick liefern können, aber zumindest die ein oder andere Eindrücke werden wir hier sicherlich nochmal aufgreifen wollen.
Aber vorher reden wir noch ein bisschen über den Terror.
Genau, weil Terror ist ja geil. Da muss man drüber reden. Da hat jeder was beizutragen. Wenn er dann passiert, dann äh.
Haben eigentlich auch alle schon ihre ihre ihre Talking-Points am Start. Ja, der Terror bei dem wir sprechen müssen ist natürlich der Terror.
Der ähm ja vor allem jetzt sich zuletzt in Berlin manifestiert hat, das ist natürlich das Thema in in Deutschland gewesen, so war Weihnachten und ist es auch immer noch.
Aber langsam zeichnet sich halt ab, was eigentlich hier passiert ist. Also ganz klar, es hat diesen Anschlag gegeben.
Es gab einen Attentäter, vermutlich, also vermutlich einen der im Wesentlichen, äh, das geplant hat, ob da noch andere Leute eine Rolle gespielt haben, wissen wir nicht.
Doch, dass dass scheint sie jetzt schon so ein bisschen zu zeigen, dass es da andere, dass da andere Personen eine Rolle gespielt.
Ja, weil in welchem Maße die sozusagen eine Rolle gespielt haben, was.
Tat, ja?
Also es äh es ist ein Mensch namens Anis Amri in in einen Weihnachtsmarkt gefahren mit einem gestohlenen LKW und hat dabei äh mehrere Menschen getötet und viele schwer verletzt.
Und das äh in Berlin auf dem Breitscheidplatz am neunzehnten Dezember. Wenige Tage vor Weihnachten.
Und ähm es war.
Im Prinzip waren also die eine Reaktion war eh vorhersehbar, dass es natürlich das danach dann alle möglichen Sicherheitsgesetze Forderungen, Verschärfungen und so weiter ähm gefordert werden natürlich auch, dass ähm.
Ja, Ausländer äh und ähm Asylsuchende in Deutschland äh da eine schwere Zeit dran haben würden in der Folge. Ähm.
Aber was mich tatsächlich doch echt überrascht hat war, dass eigentlich Berlin und Deutschland dann doch recht cool geblieben sind.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich wieder das Blasenproblem so, ich welcher Teil, ja?
Ich habe jetzt auch nichts feststellen können, dass jetzt so in meinem Umfeld äh alle besonders durchtreten, aber mein Umfeld ist halt auch äh extrem gestellt, was äh solche Debatten betrifft. Deswegen bin ich da sicherlich nicht der Maßstab.
Sicherlich gibt's schon in Berlin so eine Gegenbewegung, die dann eben auch,
zumindest damit äh gerne kokettiert hat, selbst bei einer vorhanden seinden Verunsicherung scheint dann äh doch so dieses Moment mit,
Das kann auch ein Seemann nicht äh äh schüttern, mit einem Berliner schon gar nicht äh vorherrschend gewesen zu sein
manchmal auch so ein bisschen das Pfeifen im Walde ist, aber man hat sich jetzt zumindest nicht in so einem totalen Heusenmodus begeben und äh.
Eine Lichterkette nach der anderen äh produziert, sondern eigentlich im Wesentlichen dieses, was interessiert mich das äh kultiviert.
So ist die Stadt.
Ja, also der der Täter, äh der diesen LKW gefahren hat, ist dann irgendwie rausgerannt, abgehauen und äh dann wurde relativ bald danach berichtet. Man hätte ihn ja jetzt gefangen und alles wäre gut und er wäre jetzt in Haft,
Ähm bis ich dann irgendwie bis man dann feststellt, wie er mist, wir haben hier den falschen ähm.
Der wahre Täter hatte seine Papiere in der Fahrerkabine liegen lassen, wo wir bisher noch nicht geguckt hatten. Ähm da ist natürlich auf Anhieb sehr komisch klingt. Es gab dann aber eine relativ.
Nachvollziehbare Erklärung dafür, nämlich, dass man äh zum zum Ansetzen von Spürhunden äh diese Kabine eben nicht betritt, dem oder betreten hat.
Die wurde erstmal versiegelt.
Die wurde erstmal versiegelt und ähm ja irgendwie einige Tage später äh wurde der, also war dann, wurde bekannt gegeben, okay, dass es eben Anis Amri war und nicht die Person, die man
festgehalten hatte und der wurde dann bei einer Polizeikontrolle in in Mailand.
Ja, erwischt hat sofort das Feuer eröffnet und wurde dann eben ähm erschossen. Keiner,
keine weiterer da, um die Geschichte zu erzählen. Äh niemand da, um jetzt an seine Hintermänner zu kommen. Und jetzt äh kommen natürlich die klassischen Forderungen, äh was weiß ich, ne, mehr Zusammenarbeit, bessere Kontrollen von.
Asylsuchenden, denn ähm er war tatsächlich als Asylsuchender nach Deutschland gekommen, ähm war aber vorher schon in anderen Ländern als krimineller Aktenkundig geworden. Ähm.
Also ein und und.
Aber auch mehrere Identitäten am Start in Deutsch.
Vierzehn glaube ich oder zwölf ähm interessant ist und das ist glaube ich das, worauf wir hier an der Stelle nochmal aufmerksam machen wollen, ist das ähm.
Der halt in Deutschland auch irgendwie absolut artenkundig war, ja? Also am
neunzehnten September und am elften Oktober hatte der marokkanische Geheimdienst dem BND und das BKA,
Vor dieser Person gewarnt, ja, haben also gesagt, der hat Kontakte zum IS, der bereitet einen, äh der ist bereit, einen Anschlag durchzuführen. Ähm.
Der äh der hat was vor, ja? Und es war irgendwie mehr oder weniger bekannt, dass er siebenmal,
Gegenstand der Gespräche im gemeinsamen Terrorabwärtzentrum war,
Äh mehrere Identitäten hatte äh Sozialleistungen in Deutschland erschlichen hatte in Italien oder wo schon im Knast saß ähm.
Anschlägen, Anschlagspläne hatte und sich Kriegswaffen organisieren wollte im Internet nach Sprengstoffen gesucht hatte und gesagt hatte, er wolle im Auftrag von Allah töten ähm.
Ist er dann irgendwie den deutschen Ermittlungsbehörden ähm haben den dann aus den Augen verloren? Und das ist natürlich ein ein katastrophales Versagen dieser Behörden, ähm die jetzt äh aber natürlich.
Das nutzen wollen äh um allerlei ähm um allerlei Forderungen durchzudrücken.
Ja, weil hätten wir denn dieses und jenes gehabt, dann ja dann, dann wäre das ja ganz.
Dann wäre das nicht passiert, dann hätten wir nicht die Entscheidung getroffen, äh ihn nicht weiter zu überwachen.
Genau, also die Kleffrunde da aus äh
Bayern und von der AfD, die waren natürlich dann auch äh sofort ganz weit vorne und zu staatstragender Mann war, umso mehr ging's halt um konkrete äh Forderungen äh was denn die Polizei oder andere Behörden denn so brauchen würden. Tatsache ist.
Hier hat eigentlich schon alles gestimmt. Man hatte diese Person auf dem Zeiger, gehörte wahrscheinlich zu den,
höchst eingestuftesten Gefährderpersonen, wie das so schön heißt
in Deutschland, also es ist nicht so, dass das irgendwie ja, da haben wir eine Akte gefunden, da stand der Name drauf, sondern diese Person ist halt aktiv beobachtet worden
teilweise eben auch beschattet worden et cetera PP. Man wusste sehr viel und man hatte auch schon relativ hohe,
Einstufung, was so das Gefährdungspotential betrifft und trotzdem hat's halt nicht gereicht. Und da muss man sich halt schon äh.
Fragen, warum jetzt irgendwie eine fordere Forderung nach mehr Videoüberwachung da äh irgendwas bringen soll, was in diesem Fall einfach mal überhaupt nichts.
Gebracht hätte und auch überhaupt nichts.
Ob nicht durchführbar wäre. Also es gibt gerade in diesem Fall genau keinen Aspekt, der jetzt wo jetzt hier irgendwie eine eine Videoüberwachung irgendwas gebracht hätte.
Ja und das ist sozusagen die die Situation.
Dann wird diskutiert jetzt ist es so,
Erstens wollten wir darauf hinweisen, dass dieser Fall ähm oder auch den politischen Folgerungen und Forderungen daraus ähm in aller Breite, in mehreren Folgen äh der Lage der Nation von Philipp Banse und Ulf Burmeier diskutiert wurden,
Was wir an dieser Stelle empfehlen und auch so ein bisschen als Grund nehmen uns da jetzt nicht mehr so im im massiven Detail mit auseinanderzusetzen, weil detaillierter als die beiden das in mehreren Freunden getan haben, kriegen wir es sowieso nicht hin
Deswegen an dieser Stelle wer äh sich damit weiter auseinandersetzen möchte oder das noch nicht getan hat, weil wir ja jetzt auch am äh
am siebten oder wievielter Januar, neunten Januar, jetzt relativ spät dran sind, dieses Thema überhaupt noch zu behandeln. Ähm der Verweis darauf. Was jetzt noch diskutiert wird, ist eine.
Eine Zusammenlegung der Geheimdienste, der Inlandsgeheimdienste, da weiß ich gar nicht so genau, ich mein es ist ein Vorschlag von Maaßen
da muss man natürlich immer vorsichtig sein. Ähm ich denke aber da wird man jetzt genauer nochmal äh schauen müssen.
Wie sinnvoll äh diese Forderung tatsächlich ist und die Probleme, die äh die Ermittlungsbehörden offenbar in diesem Fall hatten, äh tatsächlich,
adressieren würde. Aber wenn er schon ansetzt mit ich bin kein Politiker und würde mich gerne zu ähm würde mich nicht gerne zu politischen Forderungen äußern,
aber ich kann als Fachmann sagen, Komma das, äh das ist natürlich äh
mit größerer Vorsicht zu genießen. Wenn Maaßen sagt, er würde sich er würde hier nicht politisch agieren, denn äh wie wir wissen, macht er das äh mit Vorlieb und sehr gerne ähm und äh das finde ich also
Da bin ich ähm bin ich mal gespannt, wohin diese wohin diese Diskussion gehen wird
Horst Seehofer hatte ja dann direkt gesagt, ja nein, äh der bayerische Verfassungsschutz wird immer der bayrische Verfassungsschutz bleiben. Ähm ich frage mich, inwiefern das jetzt nur äh machtgeschachert zwischen diesen Geheimdiensten und Geheimdienst
Chefs ist und inwiefern da jetzt tatsächlich vielleicht Problemen in der in der Koordinierung.
Entgegengetreten wird.
Ja, auch da hat äh Ulf in in der Lage der Nation äh sehr viel Schönes zu äh gesagt und auch vor allem äh festgehalten. Das ist ganz interessant, dass eigentlich die ganzen Länder, Verfassungsschutzämter eigentlich außer Skandalen.
In den letzten zwanzig, dreißig Jahren äh wenig produziert haben, davon aber wiederum eine Menge, ja, so von äh Zellerloch bis äh was weiß ich für äh welche vergehen. Äh da haben sie alle irgendwie was auf dem Buckel, das heißt, es handelt sich um
vergleichsweise kleiner äh und,
Offenbar auch sehr ineffektive äh äh Gruppen, die wahrscheinlich auch eher so ein bisschen so ein, so ein Statussymbol der Bundesländer ist. Ja, hier, wir haben sogar unsere eigenen äh Geheimdienst voll wichtig und so bringt bloß nicht viel,
und dass dieses Kompetenzgerangel und Zuständigkeitsgerall an der Stelle die die Zentrale, die Verfassungsschutzzentrale ähm
stört, kann ich
mir vorstellen, ich glaube, dass diese politische Debatte dadrüber äh letzten Endes erstmal am föderalen System scheitern wird, wie man ja schon äh hört, weil ich glaube für die Bayern ist das eher sozusagen so ein heiliger Gral.
Ähm wobei man sich natürlich generell überhaupt fragen muss, sowas hat, um überhaupt der Verfassungsschutz äh in dieser ganzen Terrorgeschichte äh zu suchen, denn.
Wenn hier sozusagen irgendwas wirklich gebracht hat, dann ist es einfach die polizeiliche Arbeit und das das ist einfach das, wo äh worauf man sich konzentrieren sollte. Also der Verfassungsschutz hat uns im Bereich Terror auch nicht wirklich vorangebracht.
Also im Gegenteil, wir haben halt.
Ist das so? Sind nicht die sind nicht die VR, ja okay, also genau, NSU ist nochmal äh.
Na ja, also ich meine, sieht man ja, da gab's irgendwie Rechtsterror et cetera. Das einzige, was man halt wirklich sieht, ist eine eine potenzielle Verstrickung äh des Verfassungsschutzes mit diesen Terroraktivitäten, also nicht nur nicht kein keine Aufklärung, sondern,
tatsächlich sogar eben äh tendenziell eher eine Beteiligung,
was dann vom unserem Start leider beantwortet wird mit ach ja wirklich so war das, ne? Dann geben wir euch mal noch mehr Stellen und noch mehr äh ja, weil wenn ihr viel Geld habt, dann dann hört ihr vielleicht ja damit auf, sehe ich eine etwas absurde,
Darstellung ist. Also man kann hier im Terrorteil einfach immer nur wieder äh mit dem Kopf schüsseln und das tun wir hiermit auch.
So, dann gibt's noch.
Vor Ortsdatenspeicherung. Heute haben wir mal wieder die, die Klassiker an Bord. Wir starten quasi mit den mit den Klassikern, aber immerhin ähm.
Halbwegs gute Nachrichten sage ich mal, also zumindest äh keine Verschlimmbesserung.
Was ist passiert? Also es gab äh von Gerichten in,
sowohl Großbritannien oder King als auch in Schweden sind äh im letzten Jahr,
Klagen nach Europa durchgereicht worden. Wir hatten das ja hier schon ähm bei verschiedenen Fällen öfter mal besprochen, wie da der Weg ist. Das heißt, wenn ähm die nationale Gerichts
einen dringenden Bedarf sieht ähm
Die Vereinbarkeit europäischer Gesetzgebung, die ja eben für die nationale Gesetzgebung eben relevant ist. Äh mal wirklich überprüfen zu lassen und sich selber da außerstande sieht, das entsprechend zu bewerten, dann
in diesem Fall werden solche Klagen durchgereicht an den europäischen Gerichtshof, an den EuGH.
Das hatten wir auch schon im Falle der Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor zwei Jahren. Das hatten wir äh hier ähm mit Max Schrems und und äh sein.
Seinem Vorgehen gegen äh die Privacy ähm wie hieß das noch gleich? Der Golden Harber, ein Safe,
genauso.
Sein Vorgehen gegen die.
Nein, nein, ähm.
Ja, also gegen diese Safehaber Regelung et cetera. Also all diese ganzen Schritte, ne? Also hier wird nicht Europa selbst aktiv, sondern der Europäische Gerichtshof wird durch nationale Gerichte aktiviert. So, das heißt,
Hier sind Klagen gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Schweden und gegen die neuen äh Vorortsdatenspeicherungsaktivitäten in UK weitergereicht worden. Konkret stehen hier im Zentrum,
britische Data Retentionen Investition Powers Act Dripaar.
Der zwar mittlerweile durch äh den investiger Tory Power, Spill oder Act äh verschärft wurde. Sage ich gleich nochmal was dazu
aber der eben sozusagen hier,
Bestandteil der Klage war, wo beziehungsweise in in Schweden die Vorratszeiten Speicherung dort im Besonderen eben die Fragestellung, was ist denn hier eigentlich mit dem Zugriff durch äh Geheimdienste und die Zollbehörde auf diese VDS,
das waren Dinge, die zu klären sind. So und jetzt gab's dazu ein Urteil und das Urteil folgt im Prinzip
der Linie, die das EuGH auch schon vor zwei Jahren im Bezug auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gehabt hat und hat das im Prinzip weiter konkretisiert,
Sprich hier wird weiterhin große Skepsis ausgedrückt beziehungsweise darauf hingewiesen, dass eben auch eine Sicht der europäischen Gerichtshof.
Es sich bei der Vorratsseitenspeicherung um ein signifikante Einschränkung,
der Bürger handelt insbesondere, weil hier mit eben das Festhalten privater Verhaltensweisen verbunden ist, Lebensäußerung, Bewegungsprofile,
Aktivitäten, Beziehungen zwischen Menschen, all diese Dinge werden dadurch eben abgedeckt,
und diese Profilbildung, die da möglich ist, bewertet das EuGH im Kern,
einfach als genauso heikel wie ein Zugriff auf die Inhalte selbst, ne? Also wir hatten das ja hier auch häufig schon besprochen, ne? Man assoziierte früher ja immer mit dem Abhören von Telefonaten, vor allem eben dieses,
Es wird zugehört, was gesagt wird.
Heutzutage ist der Trend ja eigentlich ein anderer, man ist einfach hinterher hinter den Mieterdaten, da man aus diesen Mieterdaten sehr viel mehr herauslesen kann als aus einem Gespräch selber. Das mag dann im Einzelfall zwar mal interessant sein, aber im Kern
sind natürlich Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor allem
Nahrungsmittel für das Aufbauen von Beziehungsgeflechten von wer mit wem? Strukturen et cetera und ja und genau das wird eben vom EuGH hier kritisiert, dass eben eine,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung genau dazu führt. Und ja, sie halten also fest, dass es hier.
Dass Staaten einfach keine allgemeine Verpflichtung zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Telekommunikationsunternehmen einführen dürfen. Und äh außerdem wird hier auch noch äh Bezug genommen auf die,
E Privacy Richtlinie.
Oder ist es eine Direktive? Ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht, auf jeden Fall von zweitausendzwei. Die wird ja gerade überarbeitet. Ja, dort äh ist von Ausnahmen die Rede, die sozusagen, ne, also,
Schutz der Privatsphäre wird definiert, dann wird von Ausnahmen gesprochen, hier wird einfach nochmal bestätigt in diesem Urteil.
Dass diese Ausnahmen nicht automatisch dann in ein Speichergebot überführt werden dürfen. Also es darf nicht die Logik an der Stelle umgedreht werden, so ja, weil weil es ja Ausnahmen gibt, müssen wir das dann auch auf jeden Fall tun.
Und ähm.
Es wird nochmal betont, dass im Bezug auf die Frage, wer darf überhaupt darauf zugreifen, dass äh aufgrund der Schwere des Eingriffs in die Grundrechte äh durch eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das überhaupt nur bei schwerwiegenden Verbrechen denkbar ist und ja, dass es eine entsprechende Beschränkung eben auch in der Gesetzgebung geben muss, die das sicherstellt,
Also im Prinzip kann man das Ganze als weitere Absage an eine generelle Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh,
denken in UK und Schweden,
gab's eine entsprechende Beschränkung, nicht dementsprechend dürfte dieses EuGH-Urteil im Prinzip diesen Ländern.
Ein, ja, ein Überdenken dieser Gesetzgebung auf den Weg geben. Das mag in Schweden vielleicht passieren,
ob YouK äh viel drauf gibt, was ein EuGH äh sagt in Zeiten des Brexit, dass er immer dahingestellt ähm zumal ja eben das, was hier kritisiert wird, bereits durch die neue Gesetzgebung, den Vestigatory Powers Ac,
noch weiter verschärft wird und UK mittlerweile einfach die äh krasseste Überwachungsgesetzgebung weltweit jetzt sein Eigen nennt.
Auswirkungen auf Deutschland.
Ist unklar, ähm hat sicherlich Auswirkungen, kann ich jetzt schwer beurteilen, mich jetzt das so richtig rausgelesen habe aus den Bewertungen. Sind das halt so Sachen, dass so die Abfrage der IP äh im Netz zum Beispiel,
Derzeit bei jeder Straftat möglich ist und dass das halt jetzt durch diese Gesetzgebung des EuGH nochmal weiter eingeschränkt wird und das halt im Prinzip ja auch die aktuelle Fassung der Vorzeitenspeicherung in Deutschland nochmal auf dem Prüfstand steht. Kann ich nicht beurteilen, was da jetzt passiert
Tatsache ist, grundsätzlich die Signale aus Europa sind eben VDS ist doof. Wenn überhaupt,
Nur in Ausnahmefällen man hat nicht unbedingt so den Eindruck, als ob sich hier alle besonders darum reißen würden, dieser Rechtssprechung zu folgen, aber es ist zumindest eine Basis, auf der man eben weitere Klagen äh führen kann und
die auch durchaus vielversprechend dann sein können.
Aber das wird er ähm ich habe das schon so ein bisschen eher so verstanden, dass das jetzt auf jeden Fall die Deutsche Implementation der
ähm.
Der Vorratsdatensprecher Speicherung nochmal betreffen wird und da nochmal eine Diskussion äh auf jeden Fall auf Regio Richt auf juristischem Wege gesucht werden wird.
Ja, die Diskussion auf jeden Fall, aber ob es eine wirkliche Auswirkung hat, das war eigentlich jetzt nicht in die Wand zu mal.
Okay.
Ne
Wir werden ja eh gleich nochmal über den Kongress reden, aber in dem Zusammenhang sei auch nochmal drauf verwiesen, dass dort auch ein Vortrag gab, genau über diese neue Überwachungsregelung in den USA, an der Standing this Noopers Charter, so wie das her so
Umgangssprachlich genannt wird
Bollos Privacy, dort wird nochmal ausgelegt, was das alles für Konsequenzen hat und es irgendwie ziemlich umfangreich.
Wunderbar, das ist immer schön so, dass man zu Beginn des Jahres immer noch so auf die ganzen Kongresstalks verweisen kann. Wir machen's uns heute echt ein bisschen einfach, ne? Ja, dieses Thema hört ja mal Lage der Nation,
Inhörter hier dreiunddreißig C drei Vortrag. Finde ich gut. Ähm dann müssen wir das nicht immer alles machen.
Aber liebe Podcasts und äh Speaker, auf die wir jetzt alle verwiesen haben, ihr dürft dann auch gerne auf uns zurückverweisen. Weil wir sind nämlich hier der Fachpodcast für Politik, Kultur und Netz.
In einem.
Genau. Drei Podcasts in einem.
Ja, ein Thema, was ähm.
Was mich bei was irgendwie mich die letzten Wochen verfolgt hat und ähm gerade wenn Kongress ist,
muss ich ja äh relativ häufig auch so Pressesachen ähm beantworten. Als,
zum Kongress selber, aber irgendwie in in letzter Zeit war dann war eines der großen Themen, was die, was die Leute beschäftigt hat, irgendwie alles, was mit Cyber und Wahl zu tun hat, ne. Das war das war einfach Thema
und ähm wir haben das ja glaube ich auch in ähm.
In der Folge, wie hieß die Folge dann nochmal Unglück, im Glück, im Unglück, glaube ich, eine der letzten LMP-Folgen haben wir uns glaube ich relativ ausführlich so mit Ansätzen zur zur Einflussnahme auf auf Wahlen schon mal auseinandergesetzt. Ähm.
Ich glaube auf die werden wir relativ häufig auch nochmal zurück verweisen.
Ähm aber das das Gerücht hält sich eben vor allem massiv und wird jetzt auch durch die US-Geheimdienste und US-Regierungen quasi am Leben gehalten oder äh gestärkt. Das ist also sich um.
Das ist also massive Cyber-Aktivitäten der Russen, insbesondere Putins ähm gegeben habe, um Einfluss auf das Ergebnis der US-Wahl zu nehmen.
Schön, es ist wie in den Achtzigern wieder.
Wie war das in den Achtzigern.
Der Russe, der Russe kommt, der Russe war's.
Der Russe war's. Ich habe da auch vor kurzem ja so einen Blogpost geschrieben mit dem Titel äh der Russe manipuliert die Wahl. Da habe ich dann mir allerhand so ähm.
Ja NATO-Kritiker möchte ich mal sagen, eingetreten die denen die Ironie äh des Titels irgendwie entgangen ist und weil sie dann den Inhalt nicht gelesen haben sich dann mit ausführlichen E-Mails an mich wanden.
Das äh nimmt in letzter Zeit auch echt zu, dass man von ähm von überzeugten äh Seelen äh.
Meinungsbekundigungen, Bekundungen mitgeteilt bekommt, dass äh häuft sich in letzter Zeit, fragt mich oft, wo die alle herkommen. Ähm habe eine Vermutung. Aber.
Thema ist, war es jetzt der Russe, ja? Und ähm da gibt's ja viel viel Spekulation zu und was wir als ähm als, als.
Leute, die sich ein bisschen mit Cyber auskennen, also wir haben Cyber gemacht, bevor es cool war und so hieß. Ja? Das ähm.
Da wird man natürlich öfter mal gefragt.
Und ähm was wir wir kennen ja so ein bisschen, dass es schon relativ schwer ist, diese Attribute zu machen. Also zu sagen, okay, das war.
Also wirklich zu sagen, okay, dieser Angriff kam jetzt von dieser Personengruppe oder oder diesem Land und oder und dann,
Sogart will sogar auch noch staatlich motiviert oder staatlich äh in Befehl gegeben. Das ist echt eine, das ist eine lange Beweiskette, die du aufbauen musst und das ist
relativ einfach, äh die nicht entstehen zu lassen
wenn man eben ein paar Regeln befolgt, ja? Das heißt, dann endet die Spur irgendwann immer da, wo irgendein Server gehackt wurde und den hat er jetzt nicht Putin selber äh gemietet, um diese Angriffe zu machen.
Aber die, die US-Geheimdienste haben jetzt einen Report veröffentlicht, indem sie sagen, äh indem sie also sagen, wir haben.
Absolute Gewissheit, dass nicht nur äh russische Hacker hinter diesen Angriffen stehen, sondern dass diese auch spezifisch von Putin.
Beauftragt wurden. Und äh das ist natürlich,
Also ich finde das deshalb interessant, weil sie hat keinen einzigen Beweis oder sonst was liefern. Sie sagen einfach nur wir wissen, wir wir wissen das. Ne? Und ähm,
Haben dann auch so ein Confident Cheality Rating, wo sie dann sagen, also wenn wir sagen, äußerst gewiss, dann heißt das, wir sind äußerst gewiss. Aber sie sagen nicht, wo sie irgendwie das herhaben. Jetzt könnte man natürlich davon ausgehen, okay
Eventuell, ja, wäre jetzt nicht von der wäre nicht völlig utopisch davon auszugehen, dass die Amerikaner doch den ein oder anderen.
Äh russischen äh Regierungs äh Vertreter oder Vertrauten äh gehackt haben und äh somit
vielleicht tatsächlich Beweise gesammelt haben, die sie nun nicht mit der Öffentlichkeit teilen können. Es ist aber auch so, wenn man sich ein bisschen anschaut, wie ähm wie.
Putin sich nach der Wahl verhält wie Julian Essange sich nach der Wahl verhält und wie Donald Trump sich nach der Wahl verhalten ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt eine völlig absurde Theorie, dass die vielleicht ähm.
Ob wissentlich oder unwissentlich auf jeden Fall alle in die gleiche Richtung gespielt haben und mit dem Ergebnis jetzt zufrieden sind.
Thomas Juli, Julia Sanchof.
Ja genau äh vormals Rudio A Sanchez ist jetzt äh ab sofort Juli Asanchov, ja. Ähm also da da kriegt man auch wirklich.
In diesem Bereich, also dieser Bericht von den von den ähm wie heißt die, wie heißt denn mal Sea Eye.
Mann, wie heißt, wie heißt du dieses dieses dieses Eis hier on the Record Inten äh Intelligence Comity, genau. Also der, äh, der, der.
Der äh der Director of National Intelligence hat ja vor einiger Zeit angefangen auf Tumbler zu bloggen,
Und da wurde jetzt auch dieser Report veröffentlicht, äh in dem eben keinerlei Beweise gesammelt werden, sondern nur äh Aussagen, ja.
Und eine etwas längere Liste der Berichterstattung von Russa Today dann entdecken sie im, entharnen sie den Sender Russia Today als ein von Putin
motiviertes und finanziertes Propagandaprojekt, okay, das ist auch jetzt echt ganz was Neues, dass das ähm,
das das geschehen würde, es gab, ich glaube, Klepper forderte dann auch die USA bräuchten ein Propagandaministerium, um sowas jetzt auch zu machen, wo man sich fragt, also äh entschuldigt mal bitte, also was was die USA seit jeher an.
An Propaganda, Fernsehkanälen und Zeitschriften unterhalten und auch gezielt ins ins äh ins Ausland exportieren. Äh das ist ja dann doch ein bisschen größer als diese Russia Today Geschichte, ne? Also ähm man.
Gemengelage ist wirklich auf eine Weise absurd geworden, dass es sich wunderbar einfügt, wenn Wiki Leaks dann jetzt vor ein paar Tagen sich darüber beklagt, dass ähm,
Obama an NBC. Ähm.
Geheime Informationen weitergegeben hätte, also jetzt beklagt Wiki Leaks sich auf einmal, darüber, dass das Dinge geliegt würden.
Das war dich grandios. Da musst du erstmal draufkommen.
Man kann mit Bestimmtheit sagen, dass diese Situation, die sich da jetzt gerade offenbart, also mit einem mit.
Sage ich mal, Trump Anhängern den.
Dann doch ja wahrscheinlich glaubwürdige Informationen oder Gerüchte oder was auch immer oder zumindest der naheliegende Verdacht, dass ähm Russland ähm ein.
Ein präferiertes Ergebnis bei dieser Wahl hatte und es besser fand, besser gefunden hätte und besser findet, dass Trump gewinnt. Und dass Russland unter Umständen da vielleicht die ein oder andere äh Cyber-Aktivität äh äh.
Mit.
Gut heißt, wenn nicht sogar in in Auftrag gegeben haben hätte können äh dass Leute also das völlig egal finden, dass also ähm.
Der äh gewählte Präsident äh Trump, also irgendwie quasi der Kommentar dazu, weil ja irgendwie so ey das sind die gleichen Geheimdienste, die Massenvernichtungswaffen in den USA äh
Im Irak gefunden haben, sowas herunterspielt, ja? Du Artikel hast von eben Trump-Anhängern, die also eine solche.
Wobei es nicht die Geheimdienste waren, die behauptet haben, das gefunden zu haben, dass man so ganz nebenbei her, also das Statement war auch an sich falsch, aber das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues bei.
Auch das ist wieder, auch das ist wieder falsch, also es ist ein einziger Clusterfuck an Falschaussagen,
der sehr schwer auseinanderzunehmen ist. Ähm also Wiki Leaks, um den um das mal grob zu sortieren, äh.
Putin sagt, ach was, das ist doch völliger Quatsch, dass wir hier wir haben euch doch nicht gehackt. Äh wir haben damit nichts zu tun. Äh wer das ähm,
ICA, das Intelligenz Community Assessment beziehungsweise der Director of National Intelligence, veröffentlicht also diesen ähm
In diesem Report, in dem gesagt wird, okay, wir haben echt den Eindruck, dass wir haben uns Liegenbeweise vor, wir liefern sie nicht, aber sie liegen uns vor. Trump sagt, ihr labert alle Mist.
Die Trump-Wähler sagen äh selbst wenn es so wäre, ist doch Quatsch, wir haben so gewählt und die Leute sollen mal aufhören, sich hier aufzuregen. Das ist so ein.
Also so eine absurde Gemengelage, ne? Dann kommt noch Wiki Leaks dazu und sagt ähm Wahnsinn, hier werden Sachen gelegt, das ist ja wohl eine Frechheit.
Das ist also wirklich dann gleichzeitig sagt Trump aber er will jetzt ein Programm gegen Cyberangriffe.
Ähm also du du man versteht echt diese Welt nicht mehr. Und ähm wie wir ja in.
Wie wir in den vergangenen Folgen schon öfter herbeigeführt haben oder hergeleitet haben, ist genau das eben, dass auch das Interesse ähm das große Interesse, was jetzt eben einige.
Ähm Agenten und
Akteure in dieser Großgemengelage der Politik eben auch genau verfolgen, dass eben Fakten immer weniger eine immer weniger eine Rolle spielen und man quasi gegen,
Äh immer mehr gegen.
Gegen die Realität oder die Wahrheit immunisiert und eben immer mehr mit Glauben agiert in der in der Politik und äh das äh wird uns noch einige Zeit weiter verfolgen. Interessanterweise weise auch das Thema,
wie werden die Bundestagswahlen durch den Cyber und das Hacking,
den Russen beeinflusst werden, eines wozu
wir im Rahmen des Kongress sehr viel angefragt wurden. Es war also im Prinzip eines der Hauptthemen zu dem Journalisten Fragen hatten. Wir haben uns beim Kongress mit diesem Thema natürlich auseinandergesetzt und wollen jetzt auch hier auf,
nochmal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen, was sind denn die Wege, wie jetzt im Moment versucht wird, auf sage ich mal, die Wahl Einfluss zu nehmen.
Zunächst ist glaube ich mal festzuhalten, dass wir hier ja nicht unbedingt von einer direkten Manipulation sprechen, denn Manipulation wäre ja irgendwie okay, äh jemand nimmt sich die Wahlurne, eine leicht andere Zettel rein, dann wurde die Wahl manipuliert
oder das was glaube ich in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung äh man sich oft vorstellt ist äh die Leute
sitzen da, sind eigentlich äh starke Trump-Wahl, äh was weiß ich, hier Clinton Wähler gucken aber dann irgendwie Russia Today und aufgrund einer subliminalen Botschaft
äh gehen sie zur Wahl, wählen jemand anders, wachen abends auf und denken, oh
Ich wurde manipuliert, äh ich wollte eigentlich Clinton wählen, aber äh durch psychologische Manipulierung, Manipulation, durch den Russen habe ich jetzt Trump gewählt. Das ist ja nicht das, was hier stattgefunden hat.
Was stattfindet, ist eine eine das Herstellen einer Atmosphäre, einer Wahlsituation
in der die Menschen wie gewünscht reagieren. Das hatten wir in der eben schon erwähnten Folge relativ ausführlich dargestellt, dass man eben sagt, okay, wir wollen zielgruppenorientiert darauf hinarbeiten, dass
Trump wähler Trump wählen und Hillary Fans nicht wählen.
Mhm. Was ja auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Was gut funktioniert hat und wir wollen äh um das zu tun, beschmutzen wir das Ansehen von Hillary Clinton.
In der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung. Sie hat im Laufe ihrer Karriere genug äh geliefert, um das zu tun.
Also nehmen wir das und und ballern das mal raus, ja? Und hacken halt dann irgendwie mal den den John Podesta, hacken mal, dass der dem DNC und äh,
sorgen dafür, dass diese Informationen eben auf Wiki Leaks ähm äh ihre Veröffentlichung finden. Äh das heißt, wir haben.
Wenn wir jetzt von Cyberaktivitäten im Wahlbereich reden, dann reden wir also hauptsächlich von Leaks, ja? Also von klassischen E-Mail-Hacks, die mit mit einfachen oder schwierigeren Methoden in der Regel mittels Bierfisching,
stattfinden, also einer E-Mail, die die Person auf eine gefälschte Seite,
lockt und sie dort dazu bringt, ihr Passwort einzugeben. Das ist also ein ganz ganz einfach, äh wie man sich hier am Ende den äh Podesta zum Beispiel geschnappt hat.
Also Leaks äh scheinen hier eine Rolle zu spielen und man kann da natürlich die Fundamentalposition haben, die ja Wiki League jetzt auch immer noch nach außen vertritt, dass diese Leaks nun mal wahrheit sind.
Und der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung zugeführt werden können und sollen.
Unabhängig davon, wer sie herbeigeführt hat. Und ich denke, aus einer journalistischen Perspektive kann man Wiki-Leagues da sehr gut verstehen. Es wäre ein genauso großer Skandal gewesen, wenn ähm ein Hacker.
Wiki-Leaks dieser ganzen E-Mails gibt und sagt, hier sind die Clinton-Mails, hier sind die Podesta-Mails und Wiki Leaks sagt, oh Mann, das hat so eine Sprengkraft. Das veröffentlichen wir mal lieber nicht vor der Wahl.
Weil das könnte ja sonst dazu führen, dass Halloween Clinton nicht gewählt wird. Ja, also das wäre äh genauso.
Absurd gewesen, ne? Insofern kann man da Wiki Leaks zumindest Position hinsichtlich des journalistischen Etos äh durchaus.
Argumentativ nachvollziehen.
Nicht das Wiki Leaks jetzt viel mit journalistischem Etos äh daher kommen würde.
Wiki Leaks Position ist.
Quellen kommen zu uns mit Leaks, wir stellen sicher ob die legitim sind und veröffentlicht sie dann. Das Wiki liegt eine massive ähm
massive äh Abneigung oder Junior Sosh äh insbesondere in massiver Abneigung gegen Hillary Clinton hat. Und dass Monate vorher ja schon angekündigt hat und hier auch eine Privatfede mit dieser Person ausgeforten hat
dann nochmal natürlich 'ne andere Sache. Ähm, also wir haben diese gesamte Leaking-Geschichte und man könnte sich natürlich jetzt fragen.
Warum hat eigentlich niemand die Republikaner gehackt.
Und warum hat und wenn das passiert ist, warum hat diese E-Mails keiner veröffentlicht? In diesem aus den,
Aus der US Intelligence Community hörst du ja schon, dass es auch Hackingangriffe auf die Republikaner gab. Hier jedoch offenbar keine Veröffentlichung stattgefunden haben.
Das heißt, die haben die offenbar nur überwacht und sich angeschaut, was bei denen geschossen wird, die aber dann nicht öffentlich äh und medienwirksam ans Kreuz nageln lassen,
Also Leaks ist etwas, was uns unter Umständen in den nächsten Jahren,
und vor allem in der Bundestagswahl zwanzig siebzehn beschäftigen könnte. Das ist aber jetzt auch wirklich, wenn man sich.
Die letzten Jahre anschaut, jetzt nichts besonderes, dass das League als Mittel der politischen Einflussnahme äh entdeckt wurde und und stattfindet, ja? Das haben wir ja auch an anderer Stelle, ich meine, mit Edwards Norden haben wir da große Erfolge. Äh,
auf auf einer anderen politischen Seite.
Verzeichnen können. Hört Neues natürlich auch dieses Phänomen der Fake News, das ist etwas, was wir, glaube ich, schon relativ ausführlich behandelt haben äh in Lockbuch Netzpolitik. Aber was irgendwie,
Ähm ich habe das äh relativ oft auch im Rahmen des Kongress äh,
gesagt, die Lüge ist jetzt nichts Neues. Also die Menschen haben die Lüge schon früher für sich entdeckt
Neu ist ähm der fruchtbare Boden, auf den die Lüge fällt, also einmal äh die sozialen Medien zur Verbreitung, auch hier wieder die der Verweis an die
Buchnetzpolitik mit dem Titel äh Unglück im Glück im Unglück. Ähm.
Also die sozialen Medien wie so ein selbstverstärkendes äh.
Ventil funktionieren für Menschen, die die.
Auch solche Dinge glauben wollen, ja? Der Vortrag beim Kongress, den wir dazu hatten, ist natürlich äh Bonsai Kittens waren mir lieber, wie Falschmeldungen über Geflüchtete äh im Internet gestreut werden.
Ähm der zweite Faktor sind aber eben wirklich die Menschen, die das auch glauben wollen. Das heißt auch hier wieder.
Das Misstrauen, das gesät wird und das Misstrauen, dass bei vielen Menschen jetzt so stark ist, dass sie bereit sind, eine sehr selektive Wahrnehmung zu haben, ja? Dass du also an den Punkt kommst, dass Wiki Leaks ernsthaft,
sich gegen League stellen kann und es Leute gibt, denen die Ironie dieser Äußerung gar nicht mehr auffällt.
Sondern die äh sagen, ja das ist ja unmöglich, was was hier passiert, ne.
Ähm das heißt diese diese Verzerrung der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in die eben dieses Misstrauen reingesät wird und das ähm,
dass der Glaube höher ist als die eigene Bewertung. Das ist äh natürlich ganz spannend und in diesem Bereich spielen dann natürlich auch Social Bots, die so ein bisschen die Wahrnehmung verzerren eine Rolle. Ähm aber allgemein eben
Propaganda und die wird eben,
Leider immer einfacher und auch das habe ich bei Lockenhochnetzpolitik schon gesagt, dass wir wahrscheinlich aus dieser ganzen Sache,
nicht rauskommen, indem wir irgendetwas davon verbieten oder irgendetwas davon wirklich massiv gegensteuern, sondern was wir jetzt brauchen ist eine.
Der Öffentlichkeit, die,
sich der Komplexität widmen möchte, die die Komplexität auseinandernehmen möchte, die Fakten abwägen möchte und die eben kompetenter werden möchte,
die sich mit Dingen auseinandersetzen möchte, die sich eine eigene Meinung bilden möchte und nicht ihre eigene Meinung bestätigt haben möchte,
Und vor dem Hintergrund kann man sich natürlich sehr viele Gedanken darüber machen, wie der Cyber ähm Einfluss auf die Wahl nimmt und wer mit welchen Interessen in diesem großen Spielfeld agiert. Gleichzeitig,
ändert das aber natürlich nichts daran, wenn so ein League nun mal äh.
Verifizierbar ist, war es und ein Skandal zu Tage fördert. Insofern bin ich sehr gespannt, ob wir das in Deutschland auch in der Form sehen werden,
Wer da jetzt viele Leaks haben werden, ob die eine Rolle spielen, das wäre auf jeden Fall was ganz Neues in Deutschland, hat bisher selten jetzt so in so einer Bundestagswahl eine Rolle gespielt
dass man dann auf einmal irgendwie die E-Mails von von einem Kanzlerkandidaten oder einer Kanzlerkandidatin durchsuchen kann.
Es gab ja jetzt die ersten zarten Pflänzchen hier mit den Leaks der Dokumente aus dem äh NSA.
Untersuchungsausschuss, wo es ja auch die Vermutung gibt, dass das unter Umständen mit diesem Bundestagshack zu tun hat, über den wir früher schon berichtet haben, weil es zeitlich insofern passen würde, als dass dort keine Dokumente dabei waren, die nach diesen,
Datum, Lagen oder Vorfall äh vermutlich passiert ist, weiß man nicht so ganz genau. Ähm ja.
Ich denke was in der ganzen Debatte noch fehlt ist schlicht, dass sich eben in unserem digitalen Diskurs.
Eben sich jetzt einfach klassische Produkte,
Der Propaganda von allen Seiten äh an einem Ort zusammenhängt und hatten wir damals noch die.
Ähm ja, dem klassischen Medien, die Tagesschau, sozusagen, so die die großen Zeitungen, die so als Clearinghaus gedient haben, je nachdem, ob sie,
unabhängig davon, ob sie jetzt sozusagen
eigene Meinung unterstützt haben oder so, aber sie haben zumindest so eine Realität abgebildet, an der sich zumindest alle irgendwie orientiert haben. Mit der musste man nicht übereinstimmen und die war sicherlich auch nicht unbedingt immer richtig, aber es war zumindest irgendwie eine Realität oder müsst gab's nur eine.
Eine eine überschaubare Bandbreite von Interpretationen und ähm Dingen. Und jetzt haben wir ja äh,
diesen ganzen digitalen äh Diskurs und die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten über Jahre hin äh bejubelt.
Verweise da selber auch auf so eine Sendung, die ich mal gemacht habe, Chaosradio, eine meiner letzten Chaos-Radiosendungen.
Wo ich noch äh verhältnismäßig positiv und euphorisch so über diese Twitter-Demokratie äh gesprochen habe. Ja, so in diesem.
In unserer persönlichen Illusion, also mit uns meine ich jetzt sozusagen unsere unsere Hacker Nerds positive Wirkung des Netzes sehenden Menschen äh Illusion,
so A, wenn erstmal die ganzen guten Argumente auf den Tisch kommen und wir dann eine echte Debatte haben und sich die ganzen Intelligenzen miteinander vermischen, dann kann ja nur alles gut werden
was wir dabei sozusagen nicht gesehen haben oder was ich zumindest in dem Moment nicht betont habe
Ja, ist so, äh wenn die ganzen anderen Intelligenzen, die nicht äh gut will unterwegs sind, äh sich dort einbringen und sich dann vor allem im mit nicht so ganz so ausgeprägten Intelligenzen verknüpfen und denen einfach dann
äh Dinge vor die Nase schieben, die ihre Vorurteile bestätigen oder andere Argumente verstärken,
dass es dann eben sehr schwer wird für einen ordentlich geführten Diskurs, weil wir eben dieses Clearinghaus nicht mehr haben, weil wir das im Prinzip verteilt unter uns abbilden müssen und wir noch gar keine Antwort darauf haben. Das kann mehrere Effekte haben. Einer könnte sein
Dass durch solche Clearing Hauses bilden, das gibt's in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt mit diesen Factchecking-Websites, dass die jetzt allerdings eine eine mediale Dominanz ausstrahlen
sehe ich nicht, äh sehe ich nicht nur derzeit nicht, sehe ich auch nicht, dass sich das sozusagen ähm verstärkt. Ähm.
Es könnte eine Renaissance der ähm klassischen Medien tatsächlich
sein in dem Moment, wo die äh bereit sind, mal diese Rolle auch als solche anzunehmen, ja? Als statt sich die ganze Zeit immer in diesen Verteidigungsschlachten aufzureiben, mit wie böse auch das Internet ist und äh die Geschäftsmodelle und all das,
Ja, also hätte man sich äh in in der Zeit einfach mal mehr darauf konzentriert äh seine eigene Kompetenz zu stärken, dann wäre man jetzt auch besser aufgestellt. Ich sehe da aber durchaus jetzt auch gegen Bewegungen äh,
So, also diese, ich meine, muss man auch sehen, diese ganze Debatte mit Lügenpresse et cetera, also absurd, die auch teilweise war, hat zumindest dazu geführt.
Dass ein Teil dieser Überheblichkeit und dieser Selbstverständlichkeit, des der Medienlandschaft dahin gegangen ist.
Haben verstanden so dieses nichts. Also wir, auch wir müssen unsere Rolle neu vermitteln, auch wir müssen unsere Rolle neu
definieren, verstehen und wir wir müssen auch was dafür tun. Wir sind jetzt nicht per Aklamation und bei bei die und weil das immer schon so war, hier einfach die aussage äh fähige Kraft, sondern wir müssen uns eigentlich diese Rolle,
neu verdienen und neu definieren auch hier Licht ins Google zu bringen oder oder die die Komplex,
nicht nur Wirkenden, sondern auch komplexeinen Zusammenhänge äh in ein stimmiges Bild zu bringen, sodass wir eben darüber auch Konsens äh erzielen können.
Spannend finde ich ehrlich gesagt, dass das so lange gebraucht hat. Wenn wir jetzt mal von, wenn wir jetzt nur mal auf einer Meterperspektive auf die Medien blickt, ne? Was haben die Medien nicht schon alles überlebt, ja? Also.
Spiegel online ist jetzt letzten zwanzig Jahre alt geworden. Das heißt seit seit zwanzig Jahren müssen sich Verlage.
Mit der Existenz dieses Internets auseinandersetzen.
Ich glaube, das war eine rein ökonomische Diskussion.
Das war eine rein ökonomische Diskussion so, dann gab's aber irgendwann so, weiß ich nicht, vor wann war der wann war Peak Blogging, also als als alle am Bloggen waren? Wahrscheinlich.
Zweitausendvier ging das lo.
Jahr zweitausendvier ging das los, dann sage ich mal so zweitausendsieben, zweitausendzehn oder sowas war,
so, der so der oh krass, ey, jeder kann bloggen, ne? So, Wahnsinn, so und dann sind ja auch da,
entsprechende journalistische Institutionen draus hervorgegangen, wie zum Beispiel Netzpolitik Org. Ähm
die äh die gezeigt haben, jo, es du das geht, ne? Du kannst hingehen, du kannst ein ein investigatives äh Redaktionsbüro aufbauen, aus nichts heraus, aus nichts, aus Staub und Asche,
gehst du hin und Wordpress so.
Sagen wir aus Sternen.
Sternenstaub und WordPress.
So, ne?
Aber dann haben die, dann war das auch irgendwann wieder so ein bisschen vorbei, ne? Sie haben relativ viel überlebt und man konnte sich auch man kann auch verstehen, dass sie dann vielleicht irgendwann nach zwanzig Jahren da sitzen und sagen, na ja komm.
Äh wir haben net alles äh kommen und gehen sehen. Äh jetzt werden wir auch noch äh hier äh Snapchat überleben oder sowas, ne.
Und jetzt hast du auf einmal so diese diese Sinnkrise oder die die Rechertigungskrise äh der Medien. Diese sich auch also.
Wir sollten das oder betonen das ja auch immer wieder durchaus mit viel Mist selber eingebrockt haben. So die viele der Anschuldigungen und Beschwerden gegenüber
den Medien sind ja nicht unbedingt aus der Luft gegriffen, da gab es sehr häufig komische Vorfälle
gleichzeitig aber äh haben wir in Deutschland eben auch echt eine Medienlandschaft, die ich äh vielleicht fehlt da Leuten auch so ein bisschen die Erfahrung im Ausland
ähm mal zu sehen, was man mit den, gerade mit den mit den Staatsmedien,
mit GEZ zwangsfinanzieren müssen, ne? Was wir an den Journalisten teilweise haben, ja? Bei allen Fehlern, die auch die immer mal wieder machen, äh wie jeder andere Journalist auch, ja. Ähm
ist es dann doch sehr sehr interessant, was wir für eine äh erstens seriöse Medienlandschaft haben äh und
zweitens diverse Medienlandschaft haben. Das hast du äh insbesondere in den USA kaum, ja, dass du diese Diversität hast
diese Seriosität. Ähm, das wäre etwas, was ich mir echt wünschen würde, dass in Deutschland zu bewahren und das haben wir in das kann man auch ausbauen, ne? Will jetzt auch nicht sagen, hier bin ich, bin jetzt hier glücklich oder so, ne?
Viel kann man noch viel mehr machen und viel besser machen. Ähm aber ähm.
Ich sage mal Breitbart und äh sonstige äh Ideen äh aus der äh Wache Fraktion äh sind ja irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt der der Weg, äh den den wir jetzt als als aufgeklärte Gesellschaft gehen müssen.
Ja genau und das genau ich glaube das ist jetzt.
Auch der Grund, warum es jetzt umschlägt. Ich denke, also es ist glaube ich eine eine Gemengelage. Also erstmal man man kommt von dieser rein ökonomischen Debatte weg.
Man redet jetzt nicht mehr über das Internet nur noch, als irgendwie existenzgefährdende Bedrohung ähm wobei man auch sagen muss.
Bestimmte in den Medien und auch gerade von unserer Kulturlandschaft oft kritisierte.
Visionen äh sind auch so eingetreten,
Also ich erinnere mich gerade, was so diese Debattenkultur betrifft, wo wir, wie sagen, ja, Twitter und toll und super und guck mal, wir reden alle miteinander
Da kam dann schon sehr früh dieses, da ist ja so viel Hass, da ist ja so viel äh Diskur. Diese Debatte wurde am Anfang bei den Medien geführt und von,
unserer Seite so nicht angenommen,
sondern einfach als Verwischungstaktik und ihr schaut ja gar nicht hier auf die positiven Defekte und überhaupt und das kann ja auch alles ganz toll sein äh beantwortet und tatsächlich und ich habe da auch so den Eindruck, dass diese ganze Hassnummer
Bei denen zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon viel stärker sichtbar war.
Als als als wir durch unsere Blasen. Also es ist so eine so eine so eine so eine so eine so eine so eine Mischgemengelage aber ich glaube, dass es jetzt einfach spätestens mit den Ereignissen des letzten Jahres einfach,
so klar geworden ist, dass dass man jetzt keine Zeit mehr zu verlieren hat und dass das eben nichts mehr gesetzt ist und es sich sicherlich auch ähm.
Durch eine neue Generation, also frisch nachwachsender äh Journalisten
Aspiranten natürlich auch ganz anders darstellt. Die werden einfach auch gesehen haben, dass da jetzt einfach der Nachwuchs kommt und einfach Fragezeichen äh äh im Gesicht hat und und und die Frage gestellt hat, ja.
Was denn ihr euer Selbstverständnis? Kann man, könnt ihr das mal definieren? Ja, äh wie immer. Ja, nee, wie immer, geht nicht. Sondern jetzt, jetzt müssen wir das auch mal anders fassen und ich habe so den Eindruck, da da klingelt's und da rasselt's und das ist im Prinzip auch eine Chance, um das mal ganz äh optimistisch auszudrücken.
Zu dieser Twitter-Geschichte, also über Twitter habe ich mir in den letzten Wochen irgendwie auch nochmal insbesondere Gedanken gemacht äh.
Also natürlich ist das einerseits eine eine total geniale Sache, dass wir, dass man so eine,
Wie man da kommunizieren kann, wie man da ähm.
Auch in Kontexte springen kann äh aber gleichzeitig ist es irgendwie ähm.
Also für einen argumentativen Austausch
völlig ungeeignet, weil man da eben keine längeren Gedanken entfalten kann, sondern immer dieses fontierte auf hundertvierzig Zeichen begrenzte
hin und her ballern hat, was ich glaube, ein ein reflektierten Diskurs
wahrscheinlich mehr behindert als es ihn auch auf andere Stelle befördert, ne? Also so eine ich hab da,
vor, weiß ich nicht, weil vor wie viel, vor langer Zeit äh paar Vorträge zugehalten. Der eine war beim äh Zündfunk Netzkongress. Ähm da weiß ich aber nicht mehr, welchen Titel der hatte. Und der andere war auch beim Easterhack nochmal Trolle, werden trollen.
Wo ich mich so ein bisschen äh quasi mich den Regeln der der Twitter-Diskussion.
Humorvoll gewidmet habe und du siehst eigentlich nicht, dass die jetzt wirklich
Also auf Twitter werden jetzt nicht die großen neuen Ideen der Menschheit äh geboren, ne? Da wird da bekämpfen sich dann doch eher
Interessengruppen. Der findet jetzt kein Austausch statt, also so diese diese Hippie-Hacker-Vision von, wenn wir erstmal lange genug miteinander geredet haben, erkennen wir das große gemeinsame Ziel. Die entfaltet sich jetzt bei Twitter nicht unbedingt,
das muss man dann doch auch mal äh zur Kenntnis nehmen. Ich frage mich, was der.
Was dieses notwendige Forum des Austausches, des reflektierten Austausches und des Diskurses in der Zukunft sein wird. Im Moment scheint der größere Teil der Gesellschaft nach einem solchen nicht zu suchen,
Ähm umso stärker wird der Impact sein, wenn es dann einmal da ist. Äh.
Also sicherlich gibt es gibt es Dinge, die du jetzt vielleicht gar nicht so auf dem Zeiger hast, wenn du das jetzt sagst. Ja, ich würde zum Beispiel mal die Wikipedia da äh mit einbringen. So äh umstritten der Diskurs dort auch ist, ja? Kann man jetzt auch nicht gerade sagen,
dass das Produkt, was dort in den letzten zehn Jahren entstanden ist, ähm vollkommen out of Hand wäre, sondern auch dort.
Gibt es einen Diskurs, der die Inhalte letzten Endes prägt. Ja, man kann sich gut vorstellen, wie in der heutigen Lage der Druck auch auf diese Community ist, dort eine andere Realität abzubilden.
Mag noch nicht so stark sein. Ähm wie die äh Angriffe auf diese schnelllebige äh Twitter-Kommunikation und Facebo
Kommunikation, weil die äh sehr viel äh Effektheischender ist und und und sehr viel mehr Bewegung bringt als einen Artikel, der irgendwo rumliegt, aber er ist sicherlich auch nicht komplett draußen,
Sprich dort bildet sich sicherlich ein Teil dessen ab, was in Zukunft vielleicht unter Umständen dieses Kommunikationsmedium der Welt sein könnte,
sicherlich nicht alles, vielleicht auch nur ein ganz kleiner Teil, aber.
Denke ich, ist auf jeden Fall ein ein äh expremi ein interessanter Experimentierhof über das, wie wie geht man miteinander um? Auch
wie geht man nicht miteinander um? Gar keine Frage. Davon hat glaube ich jedes Netzwerk was beizutragen. Also ich denke auch, dass wir so in zehn, zwanzig Jahren,
sicherlich irgendwas ganz anderes noch am Start haben werden als derzeit.
Wo ich mich vollkommen außer Stande sehe derzeit auch nur ansatzweise zu formulieren. Äh was genau es sein wird.
Also in der in der Suche nach dieser nach dieser neuen nach diesem neuen Konsensus wie eine Gesellschaft.
Sein sollte, denke ich immer, also habe ich glaube ich auch hier schon hunderttausend Mal gesagt, ne? Also ist an dieser an dieser Debatte
darüber, was eine Wahrheit ist, ne? Und das jetzt und wir an dieser Zersplitterung unserer Gesellschaft in Interessengruppen
äh siehst du, dass die Grundannahmen des Systemes, was wir hier in unserer Gesellschaft führen und pflegen, dieses demokratische System
Mit der Meinungsfindung in Anführungszeichen und der öffentlichen Kontrolle und so weiter. Äh dass diese Grundannahmen eben in Gefahr sind oder einfach nicht mehr zutreffen, ja? Das heißt, letztendlich ist es hier.
An den Grundfesten,
unseres demokratischen Glaubens wird hier äh gerödelt, wenn wir uns als Gesellschaft in Partikularinteressen und parallel Realitäten aufteilen. Das war das, was,
was die Demokratie, Theorie, wie sie jetzt praktisch umgesetzt wird, einfach nicht abbilden kann, ne? Ähm.
Und ich denke da immer wieder an, also ich glaube, ist eines der größten Zitate, die die mich irgendwie immer wieder beschäftigen. Elena Rose Welt, ne? Große Geister diskutieren über Ideen.
Durchschnittliche Geister diskutieren über Geschehnisse, kleine Geister diskutieren über Menschen und ich muss sagen
Wir sind im Durchschnitt, ne? Wir diskutieren hier jede Woche über Geschehnisse. Aber ich hoffe, dass wir mit einfließen lassen, dass wir dahinter immer wieder eine größere Idee haben, wie wir uns die Gesellschaft vorstellen. Und ich glaube, diese große Idee, die die äh,
die sollten alle haben und mit uns darin übereinstimmen. Nein, ähm diese großen Ideen, die müssen natürlich mehr äh
viel mehr diskutiert werden. Wir brauchen irgendwie viel mehr Meter Perspektive
statt uns in dieser Kleinteiligkeit zu verlieren, die dieser Überfluss an Informationen mit sich bringt. Ich glaube das ist das, was auch so ein bisschen den was wir als als Netzutop,
unterschätzt haben ist, dass du mit mit dieser Menge an Informationen.
Am Ende eine zu einer Reizüberflutung führst und dass du dann wieder Leute brauchst, die dir darin in dieser Menge von Informationen äh Orientierungen geben.
Und ähm das kriegen gerade eben bestimmte Propagandisten oder wie auch immer man sie sind, nennen mag sehr gut hin diese allgemeine Verwirrung.
Zu nutzen ähm das in die, in der nämlich Menschen nach Einfachheit suchen.
Zwei Wege in dieser Reizüberflutung gibt es so. Die eine ist, wenn die Leute einfache Lösungen wollen, gib ihnen die.
Und das ist die Seite, die gerade gewinnt, ja? Und die andere wäre, wenn den Leuten, die Gemengelage zu komplex ist,
Erklär sie ihnen, damit sie auch die komplexe Lösung verstehen, ja? Das ist immer der steinigere Weg, nämlich der einer einer irgendwie aufgeklärten und wahrlich kritischen Gesellschaft, äh die wirklich äh sage ich mal,
Die Fakten kritisch beäugt und nicht einfach nur Personen.
Oder Personengruppen äh oder die Medien denen man jetzt nicht mehr glauben kann. Und diese aufgeklärte Gesellschaft ist irgendwie immer das, was ich mir am Ende
für uns alle Wünsche und in der aufgeklärten Gesellschaft denke ich ist sehr viel Platz für das, was Andre Meister äh so schön auch glaube ich hier bei Lokbuch Netzwerkticket
unter anderem eben nennt Journalismus mit Haltung. Ja, also,
sich mit Fakten auseinandersetzen, eine Haltung haben, eine Überzeugung haben, aber eben auch transparent damit umzugehen und zu sagen, ja, also wir glauben an, ne, an dieses und jenes und äh trotzdem betreiben wir hier oder gerade deshalb,
betreiben wir hier ähm den investigativen Journalismus, äh der bei Netzpolitik Org betrieben wird. Ja, das denke ich, das ist äh das finde ich nach wie vor wichtig und ich bin da immer wieder ähm.
Froh zu sehen, wie wie krass das äh von diesem von diesem Team äh von,
Von so vielen Leuten inzwischen betrieben wird, wo natürlich dann irgendwie Andre Meister und Anna Bizelli äh leuchtende Beispiele sind. Aber äh das das gesamte Team nach diesem Ethos arbeitet und wenn die so weitermachen ähm
hoffentlich noch sehr lange ähm die Gesellschaft in der Gesellschaft ein wichtiges Kollektiv bilden.
Na ja, okay, wir sind, glaube ich, ein bisschen abgekommen und äh wollten ja eigentlich noch ein bisschen über einen Kongress reden.
Genau. Das sollten wir tun?
Denn da werden, da wird, ah, sorry, das war die Überleitung, die ich mir eigentlich gerade selber geben wollte, da wird nämlich über Ideen gesprochen.
Ja, also es war wieder Kongress, der dreiunddreißigste Chaos, Communication Kongress des Chaos-Computerclubs.
Der fünfte hintereinander in Hamburg unserer vierten Location in der.
In den zwei Städten, in denen der Kongress bisher immer hin und her äh getingelt ist. Wenn man mal von einer Zwischenlocation äh absieht, die glaube ich jetzt nicht so.
Rolle spielt, also genau genommen gab's insgesamt fünf Locations.
Ja und ich habe Schwierigkeiten, diesen Kongress zusammenzufassen, ganz ehrlich, also es war auf jeden Fall eine gute solide Veranstaltung, wo sehr viel sehr gut funktioniert hat.
Wo äh es wie immer ein ähm wildes,
breitbandiges Angebot an Aktivitäten, äh Informationsquellen und und und netten und interessanten Leuten gab.
Wieder auch eine gute Mischung aus alten Hasen auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch.
Neulingen Recycling, sei es in der Opening auch so die Frage, so wer von euch ist denn hier das erste Mal hier und gefühlt war es irgendwie so der,
halbe Saal, der äh so die Hand gehoben hat, muss man aber nicht auf fünfzig Prozent Neuteilnehmer
hochrechnen kann, weil es natürlich klar ist, dass Leute, die das erste Mal da sind äh in einem größeren Maße an dem Opening teilnehmen als ähm die Leute, die das schon ein paar Mal gesehen haben.
Ja, ohne jetzt hier äh uneuphorisch rüberzukommen, weiß nicht, wie sich dir der Kongress so.
Also es gibt einmal.
Persönlich war das der obwohl ich's mir anders vorgenommen habe der der anstrengendste Kongress und das obwohl ich eigentlich.
Ich meine, auf äh ich glaube also üblicherweise habe ich auf dem Kongress sonst äh mindestens
noch ein Podcast und noch einen Vortrag und noch irgendwas gemacht. Ähm dieses Jahr war es nur quasi ein offizieller
Erscheinung auf der Bühne der Jahresrückblick des des Chaos-Computerclubs. Das heißt, ich hatte eigentlich weniger Aufgaben und weniger weniger Dinge mitgenommen, war aber ähm er war aber anstrengender, als jeder Kongress vorher, weiß ich auch noch nicht genau wieso. Ist aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt das Leid, was es hier zu klagen gibt, was mich ähm interessiert
Oder was was mich besonders freut sind im Prinzip zwei Artikel, äh die über diesen Kongress erschienen sind. Ähm,
einmal von Barbara Wimmer in der Future Zone mit dem Titel aus der Filterbubble des Raute dreiunddreißig C drei zurück in die Realität und einmal auf dem von mir sehr geschätzten Blog Hackeday, wo Aliat Williams ähm.
Einen großartigen Artikel dreiunddreißig C drei Workshop äh formuliert hat und beiden ist es gelungen diese Veranstaltung in Worte zu fassen, was mir nämlich nicht mehr gelingt,
ich kann das, was da entsteht und was da gelebt wird,
nicht wirklich mehr in Worte fassen. Das ist zu viel ähm das ist äh zu überwältigend,
für mich, um da jetzt irgendwie das noch beschreiben zu können und die beiden haben das äh haben das geschafft und ich freue mich natürlich enorm über äh über diese Resonanz der der Veranstaltung und da ist vieles
Vieles Gutes und vieles schönes geschehen und vor allem, wenn man da mal drauf blickt ähm da wurde ich von von Journalisten auch.
Vorher viel mehr drauf angesprochen und habe das nicht so klar gesehen, dass sich der Kongress natürlich so in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Also wenn man jetzt den den letzten Kongress in Berlin nimmt, den achtundzwanzig C drei äh und den mal jetzt so mit dem einunddreißig, zweiunddreißig, dreiunddreißig, C drei Vergleich, dass sich die Veranstaltung schon sehr stark gewandelt hat.
Das ist eine eine sehr viel buntere, sehr viel offenere.
Ähm sehr viel diversere Veranstaltungen geworden. Und da gehen viele, viele Projekte ähm Hand in Hand.
Die dazu geführt haben.
Ich würde von äh ich würde vom Kongress vier Punkt vier reden.
Okay. Der Kongress vier Punkt vier. Also es gibt eine, es ist eine eine Veranstaltung für eine sehr viel breitere Community geworden
in der es glaube ich großartig gelingt viele verschiedene Interessen und äh zu vereinen,
ja? Mit einer größeren politischen Perspektive vielleicht mit einer breiteren politischen Perspektive. Ich fand das immer spannend. Äh viele Leute haben mich dann gefragt, ja der Kongress ist ja jetzt politisch geworden. Also jetzt.
Freunde, ich bitte euch. Also das war schon immer eine, das war schon immer eine politische Veranstaltung, ne? Und ähm.
Wurde bloß nicht unbedingt in der Öffentlichkeit als solche wahrgenommen.
Ja oder war vielleicht politisch zentrierter jetzt in diesem Jahr haben wir uns äh äh in dem Programm viel mit ähm.
Dieser ganzen mit diesem Rechtsruck auseinandergesetzt und das haben Leute natürlich auch gemerkt, dass äh dass das natürlich ein ein Fortschreiten in einen nicht klassischen.
Hackerbereich war, der da einen großen Teil der des oder einen einen signifikanten Teil des Programmes ausgemacht hat. Ähm,
Das ähm haben die Leute bemerkt und auch sehr positiv aufgefasst, ja? Ähm insofern ja.
Der der Kongress ist ja ist irgendwie einmalig und äh ein Wahnsinnsevent und was was da entsteht. Ich meine, du hast ja als wenn du jetzt,
in die
Organisation des Events eingebunden bist, dann weißt du natürlich, was im Programm sein wird. Ich habe ja, war ja an der Auswahl des Programmes beteiligt. Ähm du weißt, wie wie der gestalterisch äh.
Stattfinden wird und du weißt auch vorher schon welche Samlis da sein werden. Ähm aber der Kongress ist irgendwie dann mehr als die Summe seiner Teile und das, was es, was das Event wirklich ausmacht, sind dann ist dann eben das, was dort geschieht.
Ähm.
Auf der menschlichen zwischenmenschlichen Ebene, also das was die Freiwilligen dort leisten, was Menschen da für eine Begeisterung hinschleppen. Was die Leute da einfach so als als Seitending einfach mal,
Zack hochploppen und für für wunderbare Situationen schaffen.
Gesprächssituationen und gemeinsame Situationen. Das ist das, was ähm.
Was die Besucher und die Besuchenden also quasi gemeinsam dort herstellen und was diese Community da schafft. Und dafür kann der, kann der, kann der CC als Orga immer nur den Nährboden bereitstellen,
Kannst natürlich planen, okay, wir haben eine schöne Partylocation, da wird im Zweifelsfall werden die Leute sich da gut vertragen und zusammen feiern. Aber was äh.
Jetzt irgendwie auch so keine Ahnung ich kann das sagen, weil ich, weil ich äh weil ich das von vollständig von außen beobachte, Sendezentrum, ja, hier Tim kann ich,
mal deine Leute loben. Ja, das ist ja auch irgendwie eine eine Idee, die du irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren mal hattest so, machen wir vielleicht mal ein Esambly. Inzwischen gibt's da irgendwie die
Podcast-Patinnen und das das Wok ist mit dabei mit Livestreaming und Pipapo was da an von Freiwilligen.
Für einen Enthusiasmus,
zusammengetragen wird und in vielen anderen Essen auch. Ähm Chaos macht Schule mit dem Junghacker-Tag. Äh das sind so die Dinge, die die mich dann irgendwie total.
Faszinierend, begeisternd, die für mich diese Veranstaltung ausmachen.
Oder der großartige Kidsbase in diesem Ja.
Der Kids Base Wahnsinn, ja? Also, und das ist auch immer das Doofe, warum ich jetzt gar nicht anfangen will, aufzuzählen, weil man äh weil es so viel da gibt und vieles von dem vielleicht, was ich gar nicht gesehen habe.
Das äh haut mich echt regelmäßig aus den Latschen und ähm ich bin jetzt auch wirklich gerade mal äh wieder am Anfang so, dass ich mich jetzt wieder mal einer normalen geordneten Woche widmen kann, weil man das irgendwie auch erstmal verarbeiten muss alles, ne.
Ist echt krass. Ja. Ich dachte, du fragst jetzt mal nach, weil ich irgendwie gesagt habe, dass es für mich Kongress vier vier, das war nämlich jetzt nicht nur irgendwie so der Hergesagt.
Nee, ich habe nur auf die Uhr geguckt und habe mir gedacht, Scheiße, wenn der jetzt.
Wenn wir das jetzt auch noch aufpassen, dann.
Erzähl, mach, nein, das ist spannend. Lass uns, lass uns auf, lass uns auf den, lass uns in diese Richtung gehen, weil äh wie geil der Kongress ist, haben alle anderen vor uns auch schon gesagt, wir sind ja spät dran.
Ja ja genau und ich habe die Woche auch noch Freakshower, müssen wir das ja auch nochmal irgendwie zusammenfassen, aber das wird ja dann eh nochmal ein anderer Blick äh werden, ne. Ähm.
Ich weiß nicht wie viel wir jetzt noch allgemein reden wollen oder ob wir zumindest nochmal ein paar äh nette.
Kongress eins null.
Der Kongress eins null, ja okay, das heißt, dazu noch kurz, also der der Kongress alles nur weiter natürlich ganz klar äh im Einzelstädter Bürgerhaus, der Urkongress, der vierundachtzig, äh, gestartet ist. Und der ist halt so in dieser Form im Prinzip,
bis neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig so durchgelaufen. Also es war quasi äh diese erste Eteration. Das war so ein reines Nerdtreffen, extrem technisch geprägt, wenn auch eben auch,
immer auch schon politisch ja auf seine eigene Art und Weise. Es muss sich nur mal die Motti anschauen der ersten Kongresse, Bürgernetze jetzt, et cetera. Also da waren Forderungen am Start und so ist ja im Prinzip der ganze CC gegründet worden. Äh das hatte da schon immer seinen Raum
Das ist aber von der Öffentlichkeit so nicht wahrgenommen worden. Und der der Wechsel nach Berlin, der Erste, das Haus am kölnischen Park war.
Meinen Geschmack gleich aus dem Stand heraus, im Prinzip eine zwei null, weil man überhaupt das allererste Mal äh sich neue äh Räumlichkeiten,
also es stimmt nicht ganz, es gab einen ersten Versuch in Berlin Fuß zu fassen, Bikinihaus, das ist nicht so richtig auf Gegenliebe gestoßen, das war auch kein optimaler
Ort, aber das Haus vom kölnischen Park war definitiv der optimale Ort und da war's dann halt gleich neu und das war so ein bisschen das zwei null. Später kam's dann den Wechsel ins
ins BCC, eine zwanzig C drei,
war dann aber erstmal wieder nix anderes als wir machen jetzt mal das, was wir jetzt vorher da gemacht haben, irgendwie an einem neuen Ort, das so ein bisschen.
Bisschen hat nicht sofort zu so einer Neubildung geführt und einundzwanzig C drei ist für mich so ein bisschen die drei null gewesen, weil.
Da im Prinzip das allererste Mal dieses ganze ja.
Ganze Content komplett neu geplant wurde. Also da seitdem gibt's Content-Teams, seitdem gibt's irgendwie eine eine organisierte äh Call for Papers äh Routine et cetera. Also all das, was heute auch den Kongressinhalt noch,
im Prinzip mit einem einundzwanzig C drei angefangen.
Und ich würde sagen, der äh ja, Kongress vier null ist dann ganz klar der dreißig C drei gewesen, also neunundzwanzig C drei war dann zwar der erste in Hamburg.
Wo man aber erstmal so nach links und rechts guckt und sagt so, oh boah ist ja geil, hier kann man ja was machen, aber man hat im Prinzip erstmal so versucht, dass das alte Modell noch zu machen, was so mit diesem albernen Zelt, was wir dann irgendwie da auf dem Pla.
Haben und so weiter, weil wir uns irgendwie überhaupt nicht äh trennen konnten, so richtig von von dem wie es im BCC war
und der dreißig zu drei war dann im Prinzip äh die Definition des Kongresses, wie er eben sich jetzt die letzten vier Male äh abgespielt hat und äh jetzt wird's spannend. Ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt wird's wirklich
sehr spannend, ob wir jetzt erstmal Version vier fünf hinlegen oder nicht dann demnächst mal für Version fünf die Tore geöffnet werden könn.
Ich finde das, ich liebe das, wie du immer so schön nach vorne blicken kannst. Aber man merkt von uns beiden, dass wir irgendwie immer noch total matt sind von diesem Ding, ne? Also, wenn du jetzt mal im Vergleich dazu die Closing äh Session dir anschaust, ähm das ist ja das, was
Kongress war, ne? Also was äh wie wie Deutsche es äh äh die Begeisterung, mit der die Leute da äh daran teilgenommen haben. Muss dazu sagen, das war
die haben dieses Jahr ähm die beiden äh von methodisch inkorrekt gemacht, Nicolas Wörl und Rhein Fnord Remscheid.
Wir haben die Clowsing Ceremony gemacht und haben da also ein, ein, ein Ende dieser Veranstaltung bereitet, dass wirklich äh,
also irgendwie einfach großartig war, ja?
Fulminant und ähm auch wirklich alle Leute enorm mitgerissen hat. Äh und da hat sich das alles nochmal entladen so und irgendwie wurde halt irgendwie spontan klar, das ist die letzte Veranstaltung.
Im CCH Saal eins vor der Sanierung, äh der Saal eins wird ja zum Glück erhalten bleiben, sei zwei nicht, der wird jetzt gerade schon zu klump gehauen. Das war echt übel zu sehen. Ähm.
Aber das ist so das, was diese, was diese Veranstaltung.
Gibt. Und das ist eben der der Kongress ist campiger geworden, könnte man eigentlich sagen. Denn das Camp hatte in meinem Gefühl schon früher,
sehr viel früher diese diese Wirkung, Communitywirkung, Zauberwald, hast du nicht gesehen, Style und äh das hat äh das den konnte.
Dieser Saat konnte sich der Kongress dann irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr verwehren. Ganz im Gegenteil, der wurde ja auch gezielt in diese Richtung entwickelt. Und das äh finde ich finde ich enorm.
Geil, aber Herr Herr, je reden wir gerade analytisch über diesen wunderbaren Event? Das ist echt äh.
Ja, ja. Ich bin auch noch dabei, mich überhaupt äh äh nochmal so richtig reinzudenken. Ich habe vor allem äh nahezu keine Vorträge gesehen, das ist nicht überraschend. Habe dann aber so ein paar äh Sachen trotzdem noch,
gesehen, vielleicht sollten wir auch nochmal zumindest ein paar äh Tipps noch geben, zumindest so im Netzpolitischen Bereich, worauf man mal schauen sollte.
Also es gab nämlich den, es gab den versteckten wirklichen Schwerpunkt des Kongresses. Also es war, ich fand das ganz spannend, weil äh irgendjemand hatte allen Journalisten gesteckt, dass der Schwerpunkt des Kongresses äh Fake News sei.
Und wir mussten an Tag null und Tag eins.
War aber selber dann eine Fake News oder was.
Also nein, stimmt ja nicht, es war ja auch ein Thema, aber es war nicht der Gesetze Schwerpunkt,
Ähm ist sowieso schwer jetzt zu sagen, der der Kongress habe einen Schwerpunkt.
Nee, alle Journalisten fragen danach, aber was gibt's nicht?
Das gibt's nicht dafür, wir haben dafür haben wir zu viele Themen, zu viele gute Speaker, als dass man da jetzt wirklich sagt, wir wir legen jetzt einen thematischen Schwerpunkt. Aber einen, der einer der thematischen Schwerpunkte war natürlich, das Verhältnis von Bürger und Staat äh,
Vorm Hintergrund des Cyber. Äh da haben wir äh ein,
haben wir dreist drei Talks zugehabt, die ähm alle drei auch vom Feedback her großartig waren. Ähm einmal.
Es ging los mit Kurt Obsal, die von der IFF über die Fight for Incription in twenty sextine, der also dieses ganze Apple und iPhone Geschichte aufgerollt hat, dann ging es weiter mit
Josef Cox, ein äh hochgeschätzter äh Autor beim,
bei eigentlich an vielen Stellen, aber äh primär weiß Motherboard. Ähm.
Und äh zuletzt dann Christopher Segorien, der Cheef Technologies bei der ACL You ist. Ähm zum Thema Stopping Glow in Forcement Hacking. Also erstmal Verschlüsselung, dann,
und dann Stopping Low and Force mit Hacking und das ist natürlich das, was uns quasi aus der IT-Sicherheitsperspektive und der.
Wahrgenommen
Staatensicherheitsperspektive, innere Sicherheitsperspektive in den nächsten Jahren noch beschäftigen wird, nämlich einerseits, dass sie unsere Verschlüsselung angreifen wollen, ja
gerade hier wieder mit der Zitis und wie hieß dieses andere Projekt vergesse ich, habe ich jetzt auch schon wieder vergessen ähm wo es um die Messenger geht
also der der Angriff auf unsere Kommunikation einmal so und dann andererseits natürlich, je mehr wir verschlüsseln der Angriff auf unsere Devices, also der die Staatstrojaner. Das ist etwas, was uns netzpolitisch in den nächsten Jahren noch sehr viel beschäftigen wird und wo wir auch äh vor diesem vor diesem Hintergrund äh des Terrors natürlich die ein oder andere
blöde Diskussion führen müssen.
Und wo wir eben auch hoffen, dass wir von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte äh die ja jetzt endlich den äh Klagecomputerclub äh äh ablösen wird
hoffentlich sehr viel sehr viel Schützenhilfe bekommen werden. Das wäre so einer der der.
Der netzpolitischen Schwerpunkte, die wir bei dieser Veranstaltung.
Genau, man sollte vielleicht noch Anna und Andre Meisters äh Talk äh erwähnen. Äh nicht nur, aber auch, weil äh es da noch eine kleine Überraschung gab äh zum Ende.
Am Ende noch eine kleine Q and A mit Edward Snowden.
Genau, der dann äh live reingeschaltet wurde zur Überraschung aller. Ich äh habe dann danach äh viel über die Obsec dieses äh diese Stunts gehört so äh dass man dann doch.
Tunlichst vermieden hat diese Information in irgendeiner Form vorab auf dem Kongress schon sich rumsprechen zu lassen, wo also.
Ist gelungen, al.
Das ist äh wohl sehr gelungen. Äh Leute wunderten sich zwei, aber warum heißt dieser Monitor mit Molton abgehängt irgendwie, der da beim Fuck steht und so weiter.
Aber ja, gut, das äh ist immer super. Ich habe äh von den äh vor allem diesen Talk, von diesem Christopher Sogo.
Gesehen, fand ich, fand ich sehr gut, fand ich wirklich wirklich richtig äh cool. Zumal es eben auch ein schönes Thema ist, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen für.
Was wir hier diskutieren und und und wie wir es hier äh diskutieren.
Ja Chris ist Überzeugungstäter, ne? Dummerweise wird er jetzt äh sehr bald zur ähm ich glaube
nächsten Monat sogar schon von der öffentlichen Bildfläche verschwinden, weil er zumindest für ein Jahr ähm in dem US-Senat als Fellow arbeiten wird.
Der wird äh seine Position bei der SILU räumen und eben von seiner ja doch sehr
starken öffentlichen Präsenz dann zumindest für ein Jahr Abstand nehmen müssen und hofft, dass auch dauerhaft dann tatsächlich tun wird, der möchte also jetzt.
Äh vom von innen aufräumen, ja.
Ja. Ja, das war ja auch so ein bisschen sein Thema, ne? Das das ähm er meinte, äh wenn wenn wir diese Debatte, die wir auch hier führen, gewinnen wollen,
dann müssen wir halt wegkommen äh die ganze Zeit immer nur diese Verteidigungsargumente
zu bringen, die von der Öffentlichkeit als na, ihr wollt ja nur die Pädophilen ihrer Tätigkeit unterstützen, interpretiert wird, was sicherlich richtig ist und hat einfach eine ganze Reihe von Aspekten
aufgebracht in der ganzen äh Überwachung, Überwachungsdebatte, wie man eben sehr viel mehr auf die Kollateralschäden
Hinweis, nicht, also Aspekte wie äh dass die Geheimhaltung durch äh Einsatz von so Imsi-Ketchern et cetera ähm äh extrem zunehmend und und dass wir es eben auf einmal mit,
Polizeisystem zu tun haben, die sich gar nicht mehr erklären kann und ihre ganze Beweisführung gar nicht mehr darlegen kann, weil sie irgendwie Technologie benutzen, die äh so tricky down mäßig von den Geheimdiensten und vom Militär
gekommen sind et cetera. Ja? Dass Fehler gemacht werden, dass man irgendwie dass deren dieses Treiben das Vertrauen untergräbt et cetera
Überwachung auch immer billiger wird und von daher eine ganz neue Ökonomie mit sich bringt
haben wir ja hier auch die Diskussion mit Videoüberwachung, U-Bahnen und so weiter, ja, die auf einmal und sinnvoll sein soll, äh, weil man ja vorher im Prinzip die ganzen Leute die gekürzt hat, die da immer rumstanden.
Ja und natürlich auch so die internationalen Auseinandersetzungen, die das Ganze zunehmende Maße äh mit sich bringt, ne, bis hin zu so einem
Digital Security die Wahrheit, dass ich halt irgendwie nur Leute mit mehr Geld eben auch Technologie leisten können, die einen auch wirklich äh schützt. Also das äh auf jeden Fall schon mal so ein Talk äh,
Jetzt schon wirklich einiges gesehen, habe im Netz politischen Bereich noch nicht ganz so viel nachgeschaut wie in den anderen. Da werden wir dann sicherlich auch in den nächsten Wochen noch eine ganze Menge äh,
Rückblicke äh detaillierte Rückblicke bieten können.
Ja, ansonsten sehr beeindruckend irgendwie, was ist einfach die der,
der Beitrag der besuchenden selber zu dieser Veranstaltung. Das möchte ich irgendwie an dieser Stelle nochmal sagen, diese Tickets sind so spotten billig für für einen viertägigen Kongress, was man da geboten bekommt, weil die Leute da hingehen.
Das Ticket bezahlen und sich dann noch darum reißen, freiwillig arbeiten bei diesem Kongress zu erledigen.
Und ähm das ist äh das kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug loben
was da getan wird, um diesen Kongress eben auch erschwinglich für alle zu halten, muss man nur einfach auch beim Namen nennen. Ähm man könnte das
könnte das sicherlich auch von bezahlten Kräften erledigen lassen und die Tickets zu normalen Kongresspreisen verkaufen würde genauso funktionieren, bin ich mir ganz sicher. Wäre aber eben asozial und äh
genau das ist das was diese Community eben auch ausmacht, dass die Leute sich da und zwar viele tausend Leute sich da bis zur eigenen Erschöpfung äh in diesem Event engagieren und das äh kann man glaube ich nicht nicht oft genug,
loben. Umso trauriger stimmt mich das persönlich dann.
Wenn mein kleiner äh bescheidener eigener Beitrag äh zu diesem, zu dieser Veranstaltung so langweilig ausfällt und so müde äh wie der diesjährige Jahresrückblick, da gelobe ich Besserung. Also wir waren einfach, glaube ich,
alle drei total fertig. Äh ich bedanke mich bei dem trotzdem vollen Saal eins, der sich das,
durch, der sich das mit angehört hat, aber ich äh war glaube ich äh Nexus und Frank, zumindest auch Konstanze, war glaube ich relativ fit, aber äh die wir drei anderen waren
mal sehr müde und sehr erschöpft und entsprechend
wenig Begeisterung konnten wir da äh versprühen für für das, was wir im letzten Jahr äh alles so als als Club getan haben.
Mein Tipp, ein ein Tag früher und vielleicht eine halbe Stunde kürzer, das könnte schon helfen.
Ja, also irgendwas werden wir uns da einfallen lassen müssen. Ähm ich bin da auf jeden Fall nicht glücklich mit ähm
wie das gelaufen ist und äh kann das eben nur damit entschuldigen, dass dieser Kongress einfach so zehrend ist und so fordernd
von der von dem was wir da halt noch alles anderes machen, äh Pressebetreuung war in diesem Jahr natürlich auch irgendwie ein enormer Aufgabe, alles keine Entschuldigung
allenfalls eine Erklärung. Äh ich war nicht glücklich mit der mit der Performance und ähm werde mir da überlegen, wie man das hinkriegt, dass das
nächstes Jahr äh wieder ein bisschen äh mehr von der Begeisterung auch vermitteln, mit der wir.
Die diese Veranstaltung hat und die wir ja auch in unserer, in unserer Tätigkeit eigentlich haben. Das hat mich ein bisschen traurig gemacht, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ich fahre dann, warum das zufrieden mit deiner äh Interviewperformance irgendwie, wie du da sich da äh teilweise auch live äh vor Kameras äh geschlagen hast da, Tagesschau zum Beispiel, fand ich hinten einen sehr schönen Beitrag, dass äh so sehr lobenswert.
Ja, freut mich. Vielen Dank. Ähm.
Mich hat ja keiner mehr zu irgendwas gefragt, bin der da überhaupt nicht mehr wichtig.
Sei froh. Nein, ich will das Lied jetzt hier, ich will da jetzt kein Klagelid singen, ich hab.
Vermisse das jetzt auch nicht so sehr, um ehrlich.
Ist äh,
das ist auch lächerlich da jetzt irgendwie zu sagen, dass das ganz schön anstrengend ist und es ist natürlich, wir freuen uns über das Medieninteresse an dieser Veranstaltung, der diese die Außenwirkung ist, ist natürlich Teil des,
Teil des Masterplans, äh, den wir auf dem Weg zur Weltrevolution verfolgen und deswegen ist das sehr, sehr toll, dass wir so viel Medieninteresse für diese Themen da bekommen und ähm,
sind natürlich auch erfreut, das bedienen zu können, aber es sind eben auch einfach mal Unmengen an Medienengeln,
beschäftigt Unmengen an an Leuten, die da äh Interviews geben. Das klingt jetzt irgendwie so, als hätte das alles ich gemacht, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Konstanze Frank und Nexus waren mindestens mal ebenso ausgelastet. Es war wirklich ähm.
Krass und ähm.
Das führt eben leider dann dazu, dass man eben bei so einer äh bei so einer äh bei so einem Jahresrückblick dann etwas ermatteter sitzt und das führt leider auch dazu, dass sich äh viele Leute, die mich dann mal angesprochen haben
eben auch irgendwie nicht mit der gebotenen Freundlichkeit und Zeit.
Entgegentreten konnte und das äh das finde ich auch dann doch äh bedauerlich. Also muss ich ehrlich sagen, war für mich war für mich schade, muss ich dran arbeiten, wie wir das nächstes Jahr irgendwie so hinkriegen, dass das wieder ein bisschen.
Schöner wird für alle, w.
Aber wir haben uns trotzdem immer beide gefreut, wenn irgendeiner mit einem Lochboot eine Politik t-Shirt umzu.
Da habe ich mich sehr gefreut, da habe ich mich sehr gefreut und ich habe mich auch äh über äh verschiedene Geschenke gefreut äh die ich da bekommen habe.
Ähm das ging mit
Süßigkeiten und Keksen äh die eine sehr gute Wegzehrung waren bei den langen Tagen los und endete mit einer mit einer Signalweste mit dem Aufdruck freiwilliges Halberwehr
die ich jetzt.
Jahren, ja, in der dunklen Jahreszeit beim Fahrradfahren tragen kann und ich mir grausen ist schon so ein bisschen vor der Dankesliste, die ich jetzt kurz verlesen werde, weil ich wahrscheinlich irgendjemanden darauf vergessen habe und ich bitte diese Person
Personen nicht
beleidigt zu sein, sondern Verständnis zu haben, dass ich da ein bisschen äh nachlässig war und mir einfach eine kurze Nachricht zukommen zu lassen, damit ich das
nachholen kann,
Deswegen geht der Dank an Andreas Arne, Benedikt Christian Daniel, Florian, Hagen, Heiko Christopher Henning, Jan Kai
Kilian, Matthias, Max Peter, Ralf, Simon, Thomas und Tore und ähm,
Ich weiß, dass ich den Namen der Person, die mir die freiwillige Cyberwehrweste äh geschenkt hat, nicht dabei habe und bei der bedanke ich mich.
Auch nochmal ganz herzlich. Ach so und weißt du wo ich mich auch bei bedanken möchte? Ähm.
Ich weiß gar nicht, doch bei Thies, weil ähm ich habe vor, als sie, als dieses äh als dieses Halber wäre
Geschichte kam, habe ich äh mal so zehn Minuten das Bundeswehr-Logo genommen und habe drunter geschrieben äh Cyberwehr. Äh wir dienen äh Neuland oder wir dienen freiwillig
und hab dieses Logo irgendwie äh auf Twitter veröffentlicht unter einem Pseudonym
Sollte inzwischen glaube ich bekannt sein, dass äh Steffen Seibert äh ein Twitter-Account ist, mit dem ich zu dem ich gute, diplomatische Beziehungen unterhalte,
Dieses, ich wollte immer mit zum Kongress bringen, Cyberwehrsticker
und äh habe das dann irgendwie nicht mehr hinbekommen und weil dann musste man das Logo nochmal vektorisieren und ich bin kein gut, bin ich gut darin. Und äh es gab aber beim beim ähm,
beim dreiunddreißig C drei dann genau dieses Logo mit genau diesen Stickern. Und ich war äh enorm äh geflasht
das zu sehen, dass dass es einfach geschehen ist. Ähm dass mein Urheberrecht mit Füßen getreten wurde.
Und äh und das da und dann da diese Sticker vor Ort waren. Das hat
das hat mich dann doch. Das sind so diese kleinen Momente, ne, von denen jeder Hunderte mit von diesem Kongress nach Hause nimmt, wo man irgendwie denkt, so oh krass, das haben die echt durchgezogen, das haben die echt gemacht und äh davon gibt's so viele, vielleicht äh redet ihr da einfach in der Freakshow drüber, weil.
Uns ist leider die Zeit ausgegangen und ich muss jetzt los.
Genau.
Wir vertagen äh das weitere unterhalten über dreiunddreißig C drei, wenn wir auch noch mehr Talks äh nachgeschaut haben und äh vielleicht auch da nochmal inhaltlich ein bisschen bisschen mehr drauf eingehen können. Äh auf nächste Woche.
Genau und äh werden jetzt mal wieder versuchen hier auch unser vierzig Sendungsminimum äh zu kommen, indem wir uns hier wöchentlich zusammensetzen und Lochbuch Netzpolitik machen.
Drei Podcasts ein.
Wochenendespolitik vier Punkt fünf. Bis denn.
Bis dann. Bis später.